Discretization or discretizing is
an important step in this whole process.
What we want to do is
have a way to convert
a real number into an integer
across a limited scale.
In other words, we might have hundreds
of individual values here between 0 and
25 of a real number, and
we want to convert that into an integer,
say between 0 and 9.
There's a fairly easy way to do that and
I'll show you how right now.
So here's what we do.
First thing is we determine ahead of
time how many steps we're going to have.
In other words, how many groups do we
want to be able to put the data into?
Like I said before,
to have an integer between zero and
nine, we would use ten in this case.
So we divide how many data
elements we have all together
by the number of steps.
Then we sort the data, and
then the thresholds just end
up being the locations for
each one of these values.
So in other words, if we had,
say, 100 data elements and
we were going to have 10 steps,
our step size is 10.
So we just find the 10th
data element and
that's our first threshold, and
then our 20th and 30th and so on.
It ends up looking something like this.
When the data is sort of sparse,
our thresholds are set far apart.
When the data is not sparse, these
thresholds end up being closer together.
So in this particular example,
our thresholds might end up
looking something like this.
And when we go to query,
when we have a new value and
we want to see what is its discretized
value, we'll say it was a value here.
Boom, it's between those two thresholds,
so it would be an 8.